robin bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
notre plateau pour parler de cette
réunion sur l'allégement du protocole
sanitaire quelles sont vos attentes en
tant que professeur favorable à alléger
au maximum pour les élèves plutôt ne pas
trop aller très vite au vu des
contaminations ou qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez alors moi faut savoir c'est
assez compliqué hein c'est cette
situation sanitaire en le vit depuis
bientôt deux ans dans les salles de
classe on va pas se cacher c'est
vraiment compliqué les parents le vivent
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que bon on
est un peu plus de clarté parce que
quand même en cours c'est compliqué on
de ce pouvoir se projeter on arrive à
l'établissement marché dans le
secondaire dans un lycée dans le 93
quand j'arrive de performa terme du bail
à 20 élèves et les cas contacts où il
est contaminé d'un seul coup j'ai pas la
classe où j'ai quasiment pas cours le
problème c'est qu'il faut que j'adapte
mon programme
il faut se réadapter on sait pas comment
il faut faire penser à vos élèves qui
sont absents aussi d'où exactement
commentaire voilà on sait on sait jamais
ce qu'il faut faire on vraiment on
arrive chaque jour on ne sait jamais ce
qu'il faut faire comment se préparer
pour adapter notre programme surtout que
bon moi j'ai des élèves de terminale on
a le baccalauréat préparer comment est
ce qu'on fait pour adapter le programme
comment est ce qu'on fait pour préparer
nos cours on est dans le flou total
depuis des mois et des mois
c'est l'impression parfois que
les élèves parfois ils on joue aussi si
ça est-ce que de se jouer à je suis
contaminé je suis qu'à contacter d'un
seul coup on n'a pas la classe ça les
amuse aussi ça le coup pendant deux
trois jours on les a pas voilà c'est
complètement le flou total donc vous la
priorité c'est réadapter la politique de
dépistage finalement à vous entendre
tout à fait tout à fait parce que là là
on ne sait absolument pas comment s'y
prendre on ne sait absolument pas c'est
comment s'y prendre les cours ne sais
pas comment les assurer convenablement
dans le
c'est complètement le flot honnêtement
pour vous aujourd'hui au vu des
contaminations il faudrait revenir tout
de même à une vie quasi normale
finalement dans les établissements
scolaires bien on n'a pas trop le choix
parce que comment dire les élèves de
toute façon il ya un tel brassage quand
ils vont passer d'un cours de
mathématiques ou un cours d'histoire géo
ou un cours de français il va y avoir un
brassage dans le couloir de toute façon
donc on est obligé de se remettre de ce
dire qu'il faut rapidement conviennent à
la situation antérieure à l'épidémie
alors je vais pas équipé du mode oui je
suis pas du tout médecin je sais pas du
tout comment ça fonctionne - voilà
supercritiques et ce genre de choses
mais il faut quand même qu'on soit qu'on
revienne à un peu à une situation qui
sont beaucoup plus apaisé parce que là
on est toujours un peu dans ce côté de
peur de 1 c'est pas du tout comme manger
à cette affaire en fait et puis il y
avait aux élèves aussi la fin du port du
masque en extérieur c'est envisagé ce
serait une bonne chose après deux ans
pour les aider les élèves à l'école le
port du masque à l'extérieur de lever ça
vous semble logique aujourd'hui c'est le
moment oui oui je pense oui parce que de
toute façon
en classe déjà assez compliqué de le
faire respecter ça le port du masque
vous avez toujours un deux élèves quand
les flots maze est toujours là en plein
cours tu te plais remets ton masque
cetera et cetera je trouve que déjà six
en dehors de la classe ils peuvent
l'enlever ça sera beaucoup plus apaisé
sans beaucoup plus serein voilà parce
que moi je peux je peux comprendre un
jeune qui a 14 ou 15 ans on me dit toute
la journée de porter ça sur le visage du
matin jusqu'au soir au bout d'un moment
il devient fou et je me mets à sa place
aussi moi même au bout d'un moment que
nous on est tous dans cette situation là
on en a un peu marre d'avoir ce masque
et moi je les comprends tout à fait donc
je pense que oui c'est déjà une bonne
solution que déjà qu'ils essayent quand
ils sont deux pour qu'ils aillent dans
la cour qu'ils aillent dans le haut dans
la rue et puis déjà il est plus à
masquer son visage et en même temps
c'est vrai que le les contaminations
samson sont toujours présents fin aussi
alors on savait qu'un variant peut être
un peu moins dangereux vous êtes
concerné vous disais des élèves qui sont
absents des professeurs aussi qui sont
concernés qui sont absents jean michel
blanquer il a déclaré avoir un vivier de
remplaçants de 8 à 11% des effectifs
totaux est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous confirmer sur le terrain les
professeurs de vos établissements à ce
qu'ils ont pu être remplacés lorsqu'ils
étaient absents pour cause de coheed
n'en ou quels contacts non qu'est ce que
vous observez sur le faire moi j'ai été
absent justement parce que pour cause de
qu'ovide pendant je sais plus combien ça
dure une semaine je crois une grand
absent ben j'sais pas été remplacés pour
la semaine où j'ai été absent voilà donc
c'est
je crois qu'il faut attendre au moins
deux semaines d'absence enfin c'est pas
possible voilà je crois qu'en fait il
remplace qu'au bout de deux semaines
d'absence alors que
on sent que une semaine à chaque fois
donc à chaque fois vous êtes absent une
semaine parce qu'on vous a dit vous êtes
positifs dont vous serez pas remplacé ce
qui fait qu'après ils vont vous mettre
vous allez revenir vous dire que vous
avez été absent qu'une semaine donc on
va pas mettre un remplaçant donc en plus
c'est pas possible de toutes façons de
faire venir des gens juste pour une
semaine de cours donc en plus polluants
faut communiquer aux remplaçants eh bien
on voit ce qu'on en est quelles sont les
thématiques de la classe et des
problématiques aussi vis-à-vis des pros
des élèves qui ont des problèmes
particuliers
donc ça c'est ses élèves donc ce n'est
pas possible en fait c'est hot
humainement ce n'est pas possible
d'avoir un remplaçant pour avoir une
seule semaine d'absence sachant que à
chaque fois c'est qu'une semaine qu'on
est absent et moi je n'ai pas vu une
personne arrêtée a juste pour une
semaine je les ai pas vus de plus je
n'ai jamais vu pour revenir aux
mesures du gouvernement par la nuit du
port de masques éventuellement qui
serait peut être enlevé à l'extérieur
vous à ce que vous avez reçus des ffp2
c'était une promesse du gouvernement
dans votre établissement
vous avez reçu des masques ans alors on
a eu des masques en tissu dès l'année
dernière quand il ya vu vous savez les
premières livraisons sedan et masque en
tissu c'est tout ce qu'on reçoit en ce
moment c'est toujours c'est masque en
tissu qu'on soit on reçoit pas ces
masques spécifiques
d'un autre type on reçoit pas d'autres
masques soit que ces masques en ch'ti
sud éducation nationale et puis c'est
toi alors plus sur le vide mais toujours
à propos d'éducation jean michel
blanquer il a suggéré d'ajouter des
mathématiques au tronc commun en
première et en terminale le ministre de
l'éducation qui est pourtant pas
étranger au problème finalement
puisqu'il il opposait son poste il
prenait son poste en 2019 et c'était la
date d'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
du lycée votre réaction est ce que c'est
une bonne chose plus de mathématiques en
première et en terminale revenir a
finalement plus de culture de matha au
lycée moi je pense que c'est une bonne
chose infosoir comme maintenant le
progrès le forum du bac à la changer
maintenant on choisit des essais des
spécialités moi je m'occupe un peu avec
mes élèves là de l'orientation de
comment est ce qui vaut quelqu'un ils
sont seconds quelle spécialité ils vont
devoir prendre moi les dernières je
m'occupais d'une d'aisé les spécialités
quitté l'agsp donc allier la spécialité
aux histoires et il est vrai que on s'en
est rendu compte qu'il ya de moins en
moins d'élèves qui prennent l'aspect mat
on se retrouve avec des élèves en
première terminale qui n'ont absolument
plus de maths sauf si ce prêt de maths
complémentaire où je paie maths il ya
les deux niveaux moi je trouve qu au
moins le mat complémentaires devraient
être maintenus moi je vais pas un grand
féru de mathématiques geffray choisi une
spécialité littéraire mois dès le début
mais je trouve qu au moins matt
complémentaires devaient être maintenus
pour tous les élèves parce que ça fait
c'est très important pour la ville après
c'est toujours important peu importe les
études qu'on va faire ou pour notre
ville quotidiennes on a toujours besoin
de ses mathématiques et puis surtout
cette culture des mathématiques parce
qu'il ya toujours des métiers très
rémunérateur il faut te pousser les
élèves verser des branches là pour
éviter d'avoir à chercher d'autres
personnes oui je pense que au minimum
mac complémentaire devrait être
maintenue jusqu'en la fin d'un terminal
donc finalement c'était une erreur de
supprimer ses maths pour certains élèves
en 1re et terminale je dirais pas que
c'est une erreur parce que peut-être que
le programme était peut-être trop lourd
pour certains donc je pense que 1 je
pense qu'il aurait fallu maintenir
un level de maths à minimale jusqu'à la
terminale et que après bien sûr
maintenant faire en sorte qu' une
spécialité mathématiques plus
approfondie plus poussées pour d'autres
ça c'est une bonne chose mais un level
mais minimum peut-être faire un
entre-deux entre ce qu'ils avaient avant
qui était quand même level très haut est
ce que maintenant on a proposé merci
beaucoup lombard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est le pain sur les france
je vous remercie beaucoup je le rappelle
vous êtes professeur d'histoire
géographie merci beaucoup